let's talk about the navigating the
crisis obviously that's got some
parallels today some differences but
maybe just like what were your big
lessons learned given that not only did
you kind of go through the crisis but
you're actually trading the exact assets
that were at the center of that crisis
yeah yeah it was a trial by fire you
know I mean you never really know you
never really know what the importance of
liquidity is until you're really sitting
front row and center and really
understanding what it means when people
can't source including me they want I
think all of us take for granted that
the market is fully functioning at most
times and even now for the most part has
been fully functioning you know perhaps
with the exception of oil in recent days
but in general you know prices move in a
relatively linear fashion you can buy
you can sell the price might be higher
or lower but you can get things done
that was really an introduction to the
fact that if somebody doesn't want to
make a price for you in the opposite
direction that you're in there's
sometimes no exit right and so trading
that book you know for Goldman
throughout that crisis I learned a lot
about liquidity we traded that at scale
obviously and so I think some of the
lessons there as well with it you know
sometimes these things can persist for
longer than you think right the price of
liquidity is high and it's more valuable
than most people think and actually I'm
sure we'll get into it but you know a
lot of what led me to you know to
co-found this business here which is
focused on private investments with a
lot of secondary market focus the
corollaries and the parallels to trading
credit are very similar to what I think
is happening in the secondary market
with adventure now and so essentially
you know what we do now is we provide a
lot of liquidity for early investors or
the employees etc and I think it was
that appreciation of knowing that you
know the quitting the only matters when
you need it you know you only know you
need it when you need it and so yeah I
think those were some of those and we're
seeing that you know for the last couple
of weeks in the market you know public
markets today right is there a complete
you know price just fell off a cliff in
many many asset classes and it's because
people literally were looking for that
liquidity yeah
yeah it's right you look for it and you
know and you have to you know you learn
you learn how to trade sighs that's why
even on the hedge fund
I think the same is true and venture
which is constrained business but you
know it's different putting you know a
million dollars to work in the market
and a billion dollars to work right and
it's not just psychology and the fear
around training large sizes there's
actually a different way that you have
to learn how to move large blocks of
risk in and out of the marketing so when
you see some of these top hedge funds
former is these large asset managers
managing these books that are you know
one hundred five hundred times the scale
of an advert asset manager it's really a
whole nother dimension to the to the
risk analysis and the skill set right
it's not just picking the right
investments at the right time there's
different ways you have to move in and
out of risk when you're managing large
books of that size and so even though
the venture capital markets a lot
smaller you know the risk I was trading
Goldman was large in the moderate size
market here in venture the markets
relatively small and so everybody has to
understand how to move relatively large
blocks of risk around when time comes
yeah and you've mentioned risk a couple
of times and I think that people who are
unfamiliar with the mentality on Wall
Street right the best of the best
it's all about risk right and it's
understanding that risk pricing that
risk probabilities of the risk actually
occurring and like that maybe any
lessons learned over your career given
the various asset classes that you
traded where risk like hey this is the
one or two lessons I learned that really
stick out my head and now you've brought
that to the business today yeah
yeah you know I think one of the large
lessons learned is that you know unless
you're in the sea unless you're managing
the risk right your opinions on the
matter are very qualitative and
speculative at best right so you often
see traders you know they don't want to
know what you think about the market
just told me your position right if
you're bullish how long are you right
I'll judge your conviction based on that
if you're bearish got shorter you I
think in a market right now whereas
we're talking about earlier a lot of
people have it and go bid on the market
etc if you don't have skin in the game
right if you're not managing any feeling
that risk as it oscillates and as it
goes up and down um you're really doing
a very different job than people you
know that the people managing the risk
right so I think for me you know some of
the lessons there are I think going into
training I thought that the objective
the trading was to predict the future
essential
right you know I used to laugh with my
flatmate about it you know I thought
that I had been given a job where I was
gonna be paid to learn about everything
in the world it's multifactorial job
right where there's an infinite amount
of inputs really fascinating right what
the taxi driver taxi driver said
mattered with the CEO said it mattered
and you sort of take all these inputs
from around the world and crystallize it
into a trading view and try to predict
what's gonna happen next what the job
really is I think at least you know in
my in my humble opinion is it's about
understanding when there's a set up in
the market where even if you can't
predict the possibility probability of
what's happening next you know that if X
happens the return might be 10 X and if
the opposite effect happens the return
might be negative 1 X right and if you
can put yourself in situations where
even if you don't have any idea I think
we're a perfect situation now right
where we're faced with unknowable risk
right there are a lot of opinions we
really have no way to quantify when
we're going back to work what the
long-term economic impacts are etc and
so trying to position your portfolio by
predicting what we think will happen
with the coronavirus is a recipe for
disaster
right that's relatively unknowable and
the market is smarter than any
individual person right some total of
millions and millions of people voting
right billions of people and so but what
if you can find investments that you
know that if there's an equal
probability of two events occurring
which is generally that the base case
for something which is unknowable if you
can put yourself in risk forward
situations where the reward is multiples
larger than the risk you know you do
that systematically and do that over
time and that's and that's how the great
investors make money you know I think I
think one of the other things I learned
is that the hit rate of the great
investors is not necessarily
meaningfully larger than the hit rate of
the good investor you know they're both
better than the hit rate of the average
or the no or the novice right but we're
talking about single-digit percentage
points right many hedge fund managers
are right 55 to 60 percent of the time
would be a very large number right but
the magnitude of what they make when
they're right versus the magnitude of
what they lose when they're
is very very different so I think that
investors and traders have to really
understand and be honest with themselves
about when they feel like the
risk/reward is truly skewed and to know
when to really push the chips in and so
that kind of bet sizing investment
sizing risk management is often more
important you know than just getting the
right or wrong view right because
because we all we all get them right